Knowing our own minds is difficult at the
best of times. It is extraordinarily hard
to secure even basic insights into our characters
and motivations – of a kind that we hope
can free us from some of the neuroses and
compulsions that spoil so much of our lives.
It is therefore especially humbling and at
moments truly dispiriting to realise that
dispelling ignorance of our psyches with knowledge
isn’t going to be enough by itself. Or rather,
we stand to realise that there is going to
need to be a further and yet more arduous
distinction to observe between knowing something
about ourselves intellectually and knowing
about it emotionally. We might, for example,
come to an intellectual understanding that
we are timid around figures of authority because
our father was a remote and distant figure
who didn’t give us some of the support and
love we needed to tolerate ourselves. Assembling
this insight into our characters might be
the work of many years and, having reached
it, we could reasonably expect that our problems
with timidity and authority would then abate.
But the mind’s knots are sadly not so simple
to unpick. An intellectual understanding of
the past, though not wrong, won’t by itself
be effective in the sense of being able to
release us from the true intensity of our
neurotic symptoms. For this, we have to edge
our way towards a far more close-up, detailed,
visceral appreciation of where we have come
from and what we have suffered. We need to
strive for what we can call an emotional understanding
of the past – as opposed to a top-down,
abbreviated intellectual one. We will have
to re-experience at a novelistic level of
detail a whole set of scenes from our early
life in which our problems around fathers
and authority were formed. We will need to
let our imaginations wonder back to certain
moments that have been too unbearable to keep
alive in a three-dimensional form in our active
memories (the mind liking, unless actively
prompted, to reduce most of what we’ve been
through to headings rather than the full story,
a document which it shelves in remote locations
of the inner library). We need not only to
know that we had a difficult relationship
with our father, we need to relive the sorrow
as if it were happening to us today. We need
to be back in his book lined study when we
would have been not more than six; we need
to remember the light coming in from the garden,
the corduroy trousers we were wearing, the
sound of our father’s voice as it reached
its pitch of heightened anxiety, the rage
he flew into because we had not met his expectations,
the tears that ran down our cheeks, the shouting
that followed us as we ran out into the corridor,
the feeling that we wanted to die and that
everything good was destroyed. We need the
novel, not the essay. Psychotherapy has long
recognised this distinction. It knows that
thinking is hugely important – but on its
own, within the therapeutic process itself,
it is not the key to fixing our psychological
problems. It insists on a crucial difference
between broadly recognising that we were shy
as a child and re-experiencing, in its full
intensity, what it was like to feel cowed,
ignored and in constant danger of being rebuffed
or mocked; the difference between knowing,
in an abstract way, that our mother wasn’t
much focused on us when we were little and
reconnecting with the desolate feelings we
had when we tried to share certain of our
needs with her. Therapy builds on the idea
of a return to live feelings. It’s only
when we’re properly in touch with feelings
that we can correct them with the help of
our more mature faculties – and thereby
address the real troubles of our adult lives.
Oddly (and interestingly) this means intellectual
people can have a particularly tricky time
in therapy. They get interested in the ideas.
But they don’t so easily recreate and exhibit
the pains and distresses of their earlier,
less sophisticated selves, though it’s actually
these parts of who we all are that need to
be encountered, listened to and – perhaps
for the first time – comforted and reassured.
We need, to get fully better, to go back in
time, perhaps every week or so for a few years,
and deeply relive what it was like to be us
at five and nine and fifteen – and allow
ourselves to weep and be terrified and furious
in accordance with the reality of the situation.
And it is on the basis of this kind of hard-won
emotional knowledge, not its more painless
intellectual kind, that we may one day, with
a fair wind, discover a measure of relief
from some of the troubles within us. Our dictionary
features the language of emotional intelligence.
Too often, we struggle to find the right words
to explain what we mean; this dictionary is
a tool to help us convey our true emotions
and intentions with economy and precision.